you wanted it you got it it still go
[__] the Lord's Day [__]
you can either lay there and watch
football like I'm Autobahn you can get
up smoke some reefer and go do something
with your life and I'm saying well I go
stab my [__] something on the
Lord's Day I went to church I saw my
daughter singing the choir and a whole
[__] deal
now it's time to sit back with the
church family and smoke some reefers of
[__] death do you understand me I'm
not gonna be bothering you people with
some ho-hum [__] I went over the [__]
before Church cuz the weed stole was up
a lane I went over there are urban trees
and they got me hooked I'll [__] up with
the [__] that killed [__] everybody
understand me this [__] killed [__]
what's that then was that dude's name
with the Chocolate Factory whatever the
[__] his name is he went down not Harry
Potter but the other [__] guy [__]
every pilot here we go you bears
[__] uncle Joey's looking good
today shark look at that
looking like Steve bond event though on
150 fifth and [__] Amsterdam it's the
Lord's Day [__] uncle Joey here
write your [__] living room
telling you how it is take a break from
the football gives a [__]
unless you bet the game we're gonna do
jumping down with your [__] jersey on
like some move the law
[__] that [__] we got tremendous weeds
today always showing up with the Zeke og
over there from urban trees this [__]
here this after glow the 20 [__]
whatever percent I don't even know it is
I don't want to know you've been that
position I don't know what it is and I
don't want to know just bring it over
and I hope your solder comes over
because I'll break that [__] the blood
testing I'm saying but anyway enough
with the chitty-chat
let's you came to get down you came to
get down me too I came to [__] get
down I'm saying the podcast will be up
tomorrow bout ah you know in the
afternoon kids are doing it nice and
early tomorrow a little change of
[__] pay so you have something for
you how hard a travel I don't want you
to miss your uncle Joey uncle Joey threw
me to the [__] wolves because of the
pilgrims listen
the pilgrims could suck my dick I'm with
the Indians anyway those [__]
showed up I installed a [__] corn the
rolling papers it's nice for the lung
I'm saying when you hear that [__]
hearing and like you about to shoot
[__] that dude at the restaurant
Michael Corleone him when he shots a lot
so when he is ringing he that means he
the [__] you're scared
your cortisol levels are rising or you
just come back to see the devil in this
case I am robbing nobody you don't see
no [__] submachine gun so I'm about
to see the devil my favorite [__]
people cuz remember I'm with you you're
with us and they want a list and they
can't [__] hang in the stand because
us look it ain't that my mom and I big
liable to learn that word I don't care
if you're Irish I don't give you polish
I don't give your Chinese they the
inning get my mud and her bingo that
means they got a suck your dick
understand me suck my dick and call me
shorty would do the shorty parlay
because it don't matter I don't want
them to know you're Shirley I want them
to know that the anytime I might a
little more wrong boom they do or like
bad in there I am joy what's with the
[__] Spanish you know I never watch
Sesame Street growing up hey what what
are you willing though
look at this guy still recovering from
leaking cake quit his [__] his teeth
everything's all [__] up he's got one
eye anyway
Irvine is sold out Wednesday night and
it sold out Friday night you [__] up
and then I ain't doing dick ain't doing
dick I ain't doing deck toe [__]
Portland Oregon and that's [__] sold
out already so you want me to tell you
I'm doing my [__] job people that's
I'm trying to take it to the hoop every
[__] day on a daily 55 still swinging
dick still going what did you do two
three times last week one kickboxing
class and two lifts in classes what the
[__] do you think you're dealing with
huh I'm losing a [__] pound here a
pound there the heart on is on cuz
that's the most important thing with
your 55 if the tubesteak throwing you
must be walking around or harm next you
know you're maybe grabbing some guy's
dick because your heaviest [__] that
[__] no [__] erectile dysfunction in
this world number you got no dignity
that's not the money to walk around and
smile at the [__] a week [__] no wonder
you got a Starbucks cup anyway
well you had them go hang out with your
friends on another boat Uncle Joe no no
this [__] here banana oh gee they only
got it by the Grahams you know why and
then after that you got a cop down by
one one of there better be a Filipino
nurse they're the only ones I could
bring you back from this [__] they got
that special yin-yang juice that's how
they bring you back
that's the one they start the Titanic
understand me he'll even Leonardo
DiCaprio if he's saying what the [__] is
this Joey I'm gonna let the fat chick
fall in the ocean I don't give a [__]
tremendous I love smoking reefer with
you people why is it's family it's a
bond we have we're doing this all over
the world has a little black kid playing
the drums right now smoking reefer with
us who's better than us nobody you know
why cuz we don't give a [__] jack we
don't give a [__]
why are you gonna give a [__] you know
where we gonna hemorrhoid I feel
depressed I'm gonna get some [__]
sunlight you never seen it depress ramp
I have you get it together get the poker
deck this thing's doubles is shish kebab
stick and there's a [__] pipe cleaner
that's how I roll
you don't got to be fancy and show
people what I know that it is I got this
[__] afterglow let's do this Oh G
push just don't let people know we ain't
[__] around there you understand
there's it now people don't ain't Joey
you showed up like a half of [__] up
fruit today
you've been watching narcos Mexico they
teach you the transition now see first
it will get Mexican brown weed and then
the Colombians are competing we started
getting weed from Panama red and [__]
Colombian gold the Mexican said enough
is enough they started taking the seed
the male seeds out cuz they were even I
didn't learn this [__] the last night
[__] the Mexican articles I'm up to
Episode five [__] tremendous you
understand me but anyway who gives a
[__] about a history lesson who gives a
[__] about all this [__] and you ain't
smoking why are you wasting my [__]
time for you don't say it tremendous I
will Express or now maybe an episode of
not both some way for the wife to call
them will to go to watch like a family
and that's it that's that it's that
[__] simple you I'm saying I don't
need twenty people need to be jumping up
and down need to show you up by the pool
look at me get the [__] out here
I'm uncle Joey [__] old school nobody
knows nothing we [__] walk in the
shadows nobody everybody else is jumping
up and down
driving night we show up in the
shittiest [__] car week you always
gotta keep them confused cuz then if
they're confused they're all [__]
balanced you same saying how do you
knock somebody out and they gotta be off
balance always remember that that's a
free one from uncle Joey today
and that's that that's it you know me
I'll be smoking weed all day thinking
about you [__] my two o'clock
I'm all giggly and nothing goes to waste
here we smoke everything we smoke
everything we don't [__] around we fill
the pipe to the [__] brim you know
saying if you're gonna do something do
something do it right don't show up at
the coffin what the [__] this is uncle
Joey you can't show up like a [__]
mama look at the a you gotta show up
[__] with two guns ready to go with
your balls hanging jack hanging I don't
give a [__] I'm a man I show up my boy
two of them hanging like the bottom of
oils clocks that [__] take always
[__] a hanging [__] I know
you're talking to my I got a man crush
on nobody I'm saying get your [__]
together
one minute you got a man crush the next
thing you're at a [__] tank
whatever groped you and they're doing
nasty things to you either end up in the
tent what's wrong with you people
[Music]
baby oh yeah now this is like the same
[__]
like a doctor you know I'm talking about
I want to thank all you people who send
love I wear my Debbie went down it was a
tough time for the [__] family but
listen this is what it's all about
when I went on the internet I put it
down because that's what it's for were
the church family we support each other
so I appreciate everything he said about
Demi Demi was a [__] soldier he went
out he went out when he came out he went
when we brought him back from the vet we
know he was dying but he came home we
took a look around he went in the
[__] cage ed him first because they
didn't want to see nobody does him in
that condition I talked a little before
I left I told my meet him at the gate
but I loved them that I'd see him till
[__] you know I'd say him whatever
the Dell was waiting from other cat and
[__] [__] and Finny they're all
waiting for you he's got a place to go I
love you whispered naziha and they kind
of rubbed my head on my lips and I knew
that he knew these [__] animals no
dog when you give an animal glove it's
unconditional but there's a different
side for that one that animal goes down
it [__] with you you don't say it for a
couple days so I'm happy I had you guys
through this this is weird to say you
guys always come up to me it showed you
I'll be worth it
you guys help me with this so this is
what it's all about we help each other
even normal [__] savages and I'll rob
you
if you fall asleep our [__] is
[__] like that but in this situation we
helped each other I smoked another one
who the [__] are you kidding
you can't walk on one leg as they say my
neighborhood you know same Park that's
so big we got two of them for you then
we got everybody you know I gotta
tighten it up a little bit more to
tighten up the act put some new jokes in
there but whatever you come for the pup
to show you they're gonna [__] have a
good time we're gonna have a good time
Wednesday in Irvine we're gonna have
another good time Friday night in there
what do you think should we do this
afterglow
why not you hear this but look how
beautiful is fine savage just looking at
oh can you imagine
put your mag in the party you can have
this afternoon you're on home you with a
bag of chips and some that's French
onion dip that you're [__] [__]
blood and particles [__] yeah we eat
a whole bag of that French I'm gonna dip
my sour cream next thing you know your
stomach hurts off up in three weeks even
the doctor can't figure out what the
[__] happened you ain't gonna tell him
the truth
onion dip I hate the whole bag with a
bag of [__] wise potato chips
it's reef this core aneurysm oh gee
gotta clear the pipe a little sort of
[__] smoke goes in there we go now
it's gonna [__] hit like a [__]
mule listen when I smoke weed I want to
get a right [__] punch to the jaw I
love it I don't want to do nothin less
you know lalala me me me me me me me oh
it all over and then over to the fat
lady sings that she's bust not a limo
right now anyway if your gamble today I
hope you [__] winning I hope you're
taking a bookmaker and shove it up his
ass if not you always got my bookie take
a chance Columbus did you don't sit
there like a [__] move the law and
that's it I just wanna check checking
with you [__] tell me you know
that I love you I love what you do for
me thank you for watching the Netflix
special for giving me the love that
means the world to me you know where I
come from I come from a [__]
different world and you guys [__]
help me put it together so oh yeah okay
Tyrone jalapeno I said yo soy yo bottle
I these are awesome
this is my color like bowling Romeo see
I would own it wrong
that's it and that's that I love you
guys have a great day with your family
Monday knocked out of the park if they
travel and be safe or you put I down
isis's everyone keep your eyes open
especially when you're going through the
[__] line watch your [__] watch a
computer and be safe okay I love your
mother [__] cuz I'll be with you I'm the
[__] flight or in the car and that's
it and that's that have a great [__]
Lord's Day with your family and get
Monday and time to suck your dick every
Monday Monday's go down you know I'm
saying Monday everybody wants to get
their dick sucked on Friday Monday I
made that day suck my dick and that's
what you gotta do to have a great day
stay black bad yeah